gonna think about me but it's not gonna
be me
is that at like 7 A.M dude it's at 8am
bro and he's holding a he's only a Fat
Tuesday
we were talking about this earlier and I
added this article because we mentioned
it but this happened in the UK
um a dude was stabbed
murdered at this one spot when the cops
went to investigate the murderer came
back to brag to the cops that he knew
what happened
I'm something of a gum shoe yeah yeah
but apparently it's like a woman default
like moment yeah that's that's a thing
though right when like when they do like
it's so the the thing that's just so
mind-boggling is the way he does it did
he go up to the cops like so what do you
think happened you want to guess you
want to guess it feels like he went so
it's like the work of an expert it's
just in the sloppiest way you could
possibly imagine to the point where this
guy ends up being arrested on the spot
and gets life in person holy [__] like
the cops but just look listen to the
stuff he says oh there's video yes
there's a body cam video of him just
listen to his dialogue please oh my God
no what happened I know the people they
evolved so
go again
what's your name
I'm not gonna tell you my name
I'm not gonna tell you my name you
[__] [__]
huh yeah
you don't know what happened
what accent is that yeah where's he from
he's South African or something they
sound British what is he he sounds weird
he sounds funny you will never solve the
crime without me Sherlock Holmes
I will get to wear forever he's
literally like tried he imagines he's
just like movie villain and that this is
gonna be this lock thing but he just
gets arrested right there they're like
now let's have a little cotton mouse
yeah just get in the [__] car dude
you're going away for Life yeah
right I don't know what happened he just
got
wait what is he saying he's saying I
don't know what he said some guy came
over and you're gonna think about me but
this is not gonna be me
is that at like 7am dude it's at 8am and
he's holding a he's only a Fat Tuesday
he's got a [__] yard of Fat Tuesdays
you're gonna think about me but it's not
me listen to that light again
[Music]
give this guy a TV show me where is he
from dude I don't know that sounds like
borax like it's like a fake accent
you're going to think about
it's gonna be mean that looks like a
Ryan character
I mean you don't know what happened I
don't know what happened I don't know
what happened he's amazing
okay couples I woke up to 70 and then
you can chase me get the [__] car
dude get in the [__] car
[Laughter]
he's coming
so so you think something's happened to
a male in this address no I know what
happened what happened tell me what
happened this city is mine this city is
mine
dude he sounds like that [__] art guy
from Ghostbusters too which was a
[__] accent is mine he is what
accent is that I don't know I do I'm
dying if you guys can he sounds like the
guy from Beverly Hills Cop the the art
dealer
that guy too yeah he sounds like him is
it like polish or something I keep
sneaking away for goat cheese let me see
if I can find his name and then you like
weapons right you like weapons his
name's markeko is maybe polish uh
let's see
heko name
um
Slovakia oh
that's that checks out bro yeah I'll
check this out yeah he's got a shirt
like he's like from Europe too if you
don't have me you don't know what
happened
well then what happened I don't know
what happened
that shit's hella classic you're gonna
think it's me but it's not me
dude but it's not gonna be me
he's like they don't even know my name
I'm not gonna tell you my name that's
the funniest response too they're like
so what's your name I don't give a [__]
I'm not gonna tell you my name you can't
arrest him if they don't know his name
but I know what happens I saw everything
so he [__] just killed someone he
stabbed the guy to death it says that he
stabbed the dude like uh so hard into
his back that it came out of his chest
oh my God yeah so this so This Guy's
nuts yeah he's jacked he's pretty he's
pretty scary what do you say Colleen you
like him is he kind of good looking
sweet
what kind of murder weapon because it
seems to be a pretty big knife yeah yeah
a big Slovakian
she's holding the knife
oh it's a bloody knife
oh you will never unlock the mystery of
why I have this knife this guy's pretty
good with a cold Steelers hats so yeah
the
um literally
he got life in prison off that was uh
the Coppola does she have backup it
doesn't look like it sounds like she was
just there like kind of she was just
investigating yeah and then he was just
there hanging out yeah guess what
happened here yeah
now I really want to know why he slept
that guy you'll never know Nick
you're gonna think it's me but it's not
gonna be me you think she was drunk I
think this dude yeah before good shot
yes do you think he was drunk and then
he killed somebody he killed someone and
then he got so um I I don't know like
upset or like guilty or whatever he just
started drinking and then confessed I
mean that's like that's a major mental
issue though because they said it was a
completely senseless attack like they
weren't there was no prior thing there's
no correlations he might be mentally ill
maybe and mentally drunk I mean a guy is
that jacked mentally ill I doubt it with
the discipline to get have a hard body
like that this guy's totally normal yeah
but that's what they say about all the
serial murders right like the Idaho guy
they have great bodies they have great
bodies and they have a great job you got
that V Line and they have cool sense of
style no they always say they always go
back to the that's the cliche right yeah
because they're narcissists they want to
see like oh what happened they're like
self-obsessed yeah they're like is
anyone watching but that's another level
to like talk to the investigator well he
makes it sound like he is 25 steps ahead
of them
while he's basically admitting to doing
this [__]
like like his next move is like oh you
have me in the cage this is exactly what
I wanted to be
right and then he's like I knew this
would happen yeah I know and there's
open bottle too just talking to an
officer like and swearing I mean he
could swear if he wants to but just an
aggressive tongue yeah yeah being like a
wild boy at eight in the morning right
it's not even eight similar to this
topic
um so my uncle was also a cop and yeah
my dad told me a story it was one of my
uncle's first days actually on duty and
he got a call for like a burglary or
something and he showed up to this place
and he knocked on the door and this
person answered and
um he was like yeah the guy ran that way
and the guy he was talking to is
actually the burglary and he got away my
uncle your uncle's like got him and then
he runs it he was like uh he went out
the back thank you citizen you'll be
getting a medal from us soon
he went over there thank you have you
seen the memes of the girl that was on
the police force that like hooked up
with the entire team and there were so
many memes on there there's so many oh
this poor girl do you think she was a
good cop do you think she would fall for
these tricks
oh she she said she was like tricked
right what the lady yeah the cop right
into sucking all that dick right she's
sucked off oh no I think she wanted to
oh she wanted to yeah yeah it was
consensual right yeah and I think her
husband knew about it too yeah well her
husband was like [__] embarrass me
like that after I let you [__] all those
guys no he's like we're gonna work on it
what if it was his kink like he's the
cook and he enjoys it there's nothing
wrong with that I get it if that's what
you're into your other officers and then
like record it so I can watch later body
cam that'd be cool but the main Fault in
all that was that they did it while they
were on duty that's the only thing right
yeah otherwise it's totally fine what if
there's no crime in that town though
did we say this already we just priced
it I think there's no crime in town so
yeah this this the stupid thing about
this guy is that even if he didn't do
that they had so much CCTV because you
know like UK has so much like cameras
and places more cameras Than People
apparently or some [__] like that yeah
they said that they would have caught
him anyways like there's there's so much
other evidence even if all of what he
said there was like just he's talking to
each individual camera
cameras don't stop stabbings you know
like people be getting stabbed left and
right over there yeah but they know who
did it I know but it's like you die and
then they get caught how do you prevent
it the crazy thing too is that um is
that this dude
was also in the process of stalking one
of his former partners so they might
have saved her life Jesus dude by by
killing another man
but what Oh you mean like no because
they arrested him before he could do
that because obviously this guy has it
incapacity to commit heinous murder yeah
people are crazy man if only if there
was a way someone could defend
themselves that was weaker and stuff and
oh she just she's feeling it what the
heck look at this not a bad photo I
don't think he's a good looking do you
think he's thinking I'm not into what
guys wow do you think do you think he's
thinking they actually got me no I think
he's like nice try detective you still
do not know who I am
that's not even my real name I think
he's gonna be your kidney here I don't
want it he's gonna be those guys that
are like I'm only gonna talk to Batman
exactly
I just love the idea that he has 25 to
life and he's just like
it's all according to plan
I wanted to do this he's trying to get
into the prison system dude yeah I like
how they always do that though they
acquiesce like the bad guys in Arkham
he's like I'm only gonna do it to Batman
and then like fine
give him what he wants and Batman rolls
up and he goes this is exactly right
what are you talking about we haven't
been a [__] glass box
but he always finds a way out
[Music]